MALE SPEAKER: Good
afternoon and welcome to
Talks at Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it's my great pleasure
to introduce Gernot Wagner.
Along with Martin
L. Weitzman, Gernot
has co-authored the
subject of today's talk,
"Climate Shock-- How Unnatural
Selection and Non-Random
Mutation are Changing
Life on Earth."
In the book they explore
the likely repercussions
of a hotter planet
drawing on and expanding
from work previously unavailable
to general audiences.
They show that the longer we
wait to act the more likely
an extreme event will happen.
What we know about climate
change is alarming enough.
What we don't know
about the extreme risks
could be far more dangerous.
They tell us that
we need to think
about climate change
in the same way
that we think about insurance,
as a risk management problem
only here on a global scale.
Gernot is lead senior economist
at Environmental Defense Fund,
adjunct associate
professor at Columbia,
and research associate at the
Kennedy School of Government
at Harvard.
Please join me in
welcoming Gernot Wagner.
[APPLAUSE]
GERNOT WAGNER: Thank you.
Thank you, John, for
the kind introduction.
I guess that big
question always is
why yet another book
on climate change?
A topic that we all should know
quite a bit about, or at least
know enough about to act.
And the short
answer in this case
is, this isn't
about what we know.
It's about what we don't.
And as John already mentioned in
the introduction, what we know
is bad enough to lead
us to want to act.
What we don't know is
potentially much, much worse.
So here is a range of numbers
that basically defines life
on earth, or will define life
on earth very, very soon.
Now, turns out this
is 1.5 to 4.5 degrees
centigrade, the number
of climate sensitivity,
which in fact only
really matters decades,
centuries hence.
It is what happens to global
average temperatures and both
of these matter-- global
average-- as concentrations
of CO2 in the atmosphere double.
And what happens eventually
hundreds of years hence.
Now, there's a few things here.
Now, first of all, we've
already seen 0.8 degrees
of warming centigrade since the
Industrial Revolution by today.
So if you look at
this range and look
at the lower bound
of this, 1.5, you
can be pretty sure that this
is in fact a lower bound.
We you will be very, very lucky
if we undershoot that outcome.
Now, there is a couple
more things here.
So this has been
with us for a while.
And frankly, this is really
the main point, that's
the core point of this book.
We happen to live in a world
where a range like this
will define life on earth.
And in about 35 years we have
learned very, very little.
Now this is literally what came
out of a National Academy study
by Jule Charney in 1979.
And here's what he did.
There were two
studies at the time.
One said two degrees.
The other one said four degrees.
Add half a degree on each
side because why not?
There's uncertainty after all.
Average to two,
declare three degrees
as the most likely value.
And we were given this
range as something
akin to a likely value.
1990, IPCC, Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change,
enshrines this range
as it's likely range
for climate sensitivity.
Decades of climate
research in between-- well
technically, I guess 11
years of climate research
in between-- many, many
years of improvements
in how we understand and
amazing improvements in what we
know about climate change.
This key variable that
links concentrations
to temperatures, what we
ultimately should care about,
we don't know much more.
1992, exactly the same.
1995, once again.
2001, we still have
precisely the same range.
Now in the meantime,
what the IPCC has done
is it has more precisely defined
what this range actually is.
But now it calls it
the likely range.
Not 67% likely.
Turns out it's exactly
defined as 66%, so around 2/3.
Don't ask why it's 66 not 67.
But that is the probability
of being within that range.
So by now we know
with greater certainty
we'll be within this range.
The range itself hasn't changed.
Big revelation, 2007.
Now two things happened.
Well, one thing happened
to the range, the lower
bound changed from 1.5 to 2.
And now you have two
interpretations of this.
One is to say, oh
good news for science.
We now have a better idea
of what will in fact happen.
It turns out it's bad
news for everybody else.
Because it looks
like the lower bound
is in fact, out at this point.
Global average warming
due to a doubling of CO2
in the atmosphere--
and double we
will unless we change
course-- will now
be at least 2 degrees centigrade
or 3.6 degrees Fahrenheit.
That was 2007.
Fast forward to October 2013.
The latest and greatest
IPCC assessment
report five, once again
hundreds of climate scientists,
several years, lots and
lots of pages and dozens
and dozens of academic
papers going into this.
And apparently we are back
to where we started in 1979.
1.5 to 4.5 degrees centigrade.
Many, many years of climate
research, decades of learning
and amazing advances in
climate research on basically
most everything else, the one
defining number concentration
of two temperatures, no change.
That alone should already
give us pause at least,
if not actively scare us.
And of course, really
what's happening here
is in this case you could sort
of reverse the 2007 argument
and say, well, really
now what we can do
is say, well, bad
news for science.
Because we know less
apparently, up to a point.
Good news for the
rest of us because it
looks like lower global average
warming is once again part
of the likely range.
Well, turns out the uncertainty
itself, the risk itself,
not knowing in itself is in
fact really, really costly.
So this isn't good news
for the rest of us.
It is in fact bad news for us.
Having unlearned, well, for
that matter, taking into account
this is not necessarily throwing
out the latest research.
This is adding research
and saying, well,
looks like taking
everything into account
the range is indeed once again
higher than what we thought.
OK, so here is another version
of the exact same story.
So we could in fact look at a
probability density function
essentially try to see what
is the chance of hitting
every one of these global
average temperatures
eventually?
And there is a likely
range between 1.5 and 4.5.
And yes, there is
a likely chance
of being within that range, 66%
which by definition, of course,
means it's unlikely we'll
be outside that range.
But we can't ignore
the possibility.
34% chance we will
be outside the range.
Now, funny thing,
of course, when
it comes to global
average warming.
or global warming in general.
We're pretty sure that
there's a lower cut off here.
Adding CO2 isn't going
to lower temperatures.
Or for that matter, where
we are today not even
having increased
pre-industrial concentrations
in the atmosphere
by as much as is
necessary to get these
temperature outcomes eventually
but only going from
280 parts per million
pre-industrial levels to 400
today not yet 560, a doubling.
Today we've already warmed
the earth on average
by 0.8 degrees centigrade.
In equilibrium, which is
really what this is showing,
it will be higher
than today's value.
And of course we haven't
stopped adding CO2
into the atmosphere
in the meantime.
So this is, in many ways, the
core of what's going on here.
It's also slightly misleading.
Because really what
we're doing here
is just looking at what happens
every time you double CO2.
Here is another view of this.
International Energy Agency, you
take a conservative scenario--
lowercase conservative
scenario-- of what is projected
will happen by 2100 not even
not even eventually, basically
this century, and we take
the number from the IEA
that tells us 700
parts per million.
They call this, by the way,
their new policy scenario.
Or in other words,
they are already
assuming that new
policies will come
in place that are
currently not on the books
or not projected to be
in place for that matter.
But let's just give everyone
the benefit of the doubt.
We will act.
We will add new policies
despite that by 2100 we
will be at 700 parts per million
of CO2 equivalent emissions
in the atmosphere.
So we have more than
doubled concentrations.
What are the
temperature outcomes?
Well, now we are
looking at a 10% chance
of let's say,
temperatures exceeding
six degrees centigrade,
11 degrees Fahrenheit.
But this is, by definition,
on the unlikely side
of our outcome.
It's not what we expect to be.
The expectation is lower.
But of course we can't
exclude that a priori.
Here's a slightly
different view of this.
And of course the title
gives away the punch line.
What everyone is focused
on, climate scientists,
the IPCC Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change, everyone
is focused on this top line.
The median temperature
is the average.
Today we are already at 400
parts per million for CO2
alone.
This is CO2 equivalent emissions
where we are about 450.
Plus, minus a few.
So we have basically
already locked
in global average warming
off these 0.8 so degrees
centigrade.
And now we can consult
climate scientists
and they will tell well,
there's a good reason
we've chosen 2 degrees as
a threshold or some might
disagree and say,
actually, really we
ought to go back to be
pre-industrial levels
and limit warming
to 1.5 degrees.
Lots of debates to be had.
What is non debatable is that
that global average will go up
the more CO2 we add
to the atmosphere.
And it'll go up by an
enough and of course,
when you look at 700 PPM,
3.4 degrees centigrade
of global average warming
is really, really bad.
Just to give you
a sense of this,
how it relates to
us today, well,
today at 400 parts per
million we have, in fact,
experienced this before.
The planet has
We of course haven't.
Last time that was the case was
more than 3 million years ago.
Pliocene the geological
period and when
you look at the record,
we had camels in Canada,
crocodiles in Montana.
Sea levels were up
to 60 feet higher
than they are today, 20 meters
higher than they are today.
Now, no one necessarily
predicts that this
will in fact happen based
on today's concentrations.
But of course, once again,
it points to the fact
that we actually know a lot
less then we often think we do.
And that not knowing
can only be costly.
Now here is an even more
concrete manifestation
of this how not
knowing is costly.
Look at the bottom line.
The median, the mean
goes up quite a bit.
And that's costly and important.
Now, no one would
disagree with six degrees
average global warming.
Which, by the way, means
polls of warming by at least
around three times as much.
So bad news for your
beachfront property.
That's if you two degrees
of warming, let alone six.
No one would disagree that this
is a planetary catastrophe.
And look at the probabilities
of that happening
as we creep up when it comes
to concentrations of CO2
in the atmosphere.
So right now we are
basically at around 0.3%
which is not nothing.
But at least it's less
than one in this case.
Well, if you increase
concentrations from 450 to 550,
which we will surely do
unless we take really,
really strong
action, you've just
increased the chance of global
average temperatures exceeding
six degrees centigrade
by a factor of what?
10X.
That is huge.
700 PPM you have a
probability of above 10%.
We insure our houses, our lives,
our cars for a much, much lower
probabilities.
And of course, insurance has
a very particular meaning
in that case.
You pay an annual
premium in order
for if that eventuality
in fact happens
you get all your money back.
In this case, there
is no such thing
as insurance in
the sense of well,
let's just wait what happens.
If it's bad we'll
somehow make sure
that we are made whole again.
The only insurance
in this case, really,
is putting the
price on CO2 today,
avoiding emissions today.
That's where the insurance
analogy comes to play.
Now, so far I've told you
that what we care about
is temperatures.
Not the concentrations,
temperatures.
And there's a lot of uncertainty
linking one to the other.
It's not uncertain
that it'll be bad.
It's just uncertain how
bad it will, in fact, be.
Now really, we actually don't
care about temperatures either.
You care about the
damages associated
with those temperatures.
If this wasn't
already scary enough,
well, this is where
it gets really tricky.
Because now we need
to make assumptions
of what will happen in
terms of economic damages
once global average warming
hits certain thresholds.
And we've already
passed one degree.
Sorry, we have passed 0.8
degrees at this point.
But we are closer
to one degrees.
Right?
So we can look at
actual experience.
How much are hurricanes?
How much are droughts?
How much are anything that's
linked with global warming
today already costing us today?
And then of course, you can
look at many, many, many studies
that are going to
project, are projecting
what will happen as well, you
creep up just a little bit.
From 1 to 1.2 or from
1 to 1.5 and so on.
What happens at
relatively low levels?
No one has any idea what the
actual damages are at let's say
five or six degrees centigrade
of global average warming.
Now, that doesn't stop
economists of course.
Right?
So what do economists do?
Well, we somehow need
to make assumptions.
We need to extrapolate
based on actual experience
of projections of what we
do know into the unknown
or I would argue in
many ways unknowable.
Well, when you look at the
standard assumptions feeding
into the three models that
are used most prominently
to calculate what climate
change is actually costing us
every single one of
them assumes something
akin to this bottom line here,
a quadratic extrapolation.
What does that mean in English?
Well, no one really believes
it's a straight line
as in the warmer it
gets we just keep adding
sort of a bit of damages.
Well, the warmer it gets
once you hit certain
thresholds the higher the costs
of any additional warming.
Hence not a straight line but
one that curves slightly up.
Now, of course we
don't in fact know how
that line ought to look like.
Whether this quadratic
extrapolation here is in fact
correct.
Now, we are not saying that
the red line here is anymore
correct then the quadratic one,
the exponential extrapolation.
The point is we just don't know.
What we do know is that
this quadratic extrapolation
is in fact rather conservative.
Very, very conservative,
lowercase conservative
when you try to estimate
what the actual damages are.
And the difference
is, in fact, dramatic.
At one degrees or four
degrees, well, in fact,
they're exactly the same.
There is no difference.
At six degrees, this is looking
at average global damages
as a percent of global
economic output.
You're now looking at a
difference between 10 and 30%.
Those numbers are a trillion
here, trillion there.
Soon enough you're
talking real bucks.
So this starts adding up here.
And once again, lots
of uncertainty what it
actually is.
We can be pretty
sure it's not going
to be below the blue line.
Although of course,
that is uncertain too.
What, of course,
should really scares
us is that there's
a potential to have
this go quite a bit higher.
OK, now here's what we
know-- or at least what
the models that have the
known knowns and some
of the known unknowns
and footnote somewhere.
But certainly none of the
stuff that it could potentially
really cost us big time--
those three economic models
climate economic models
that essentially look
at damages that we can
estimate grind the cranks,
feed them through some pretty
sophisticated calculations,
come up with $40 per
ton of CO2 as the cost.
Now that's $40 per ton
of CO2 emitted today
in today's dollars.
That that ton of CO2, once
it's up in atmosphere,
will cause over its lifetime.
Stuff stays up there for
centuries, millennia.
So much of the damage is
in fact in the future.
Much of the damage
is in fact not
affecting us but our
children or others children.
Which of course, once
again, is the problem,
why the global warming such a
big problem in the first place.
Nevertheless, when you
calculate the cost of each ton
you and I emit
today it's that $40.
The known knowns.
If you take the unknown
unknowns seriously,
it's pretty clear that
it can only go up.
Here's where we are today.
When you look at
fossil fuel subsidies,
half a trillion
dollars per year.
Average it out.
The global average price
is in fact negative.
Now, of course that's
not true everywhere.
Those subsidies are concentrated
in particular countries.
Still, on average, we
are not even getting
the sign right, let alone
getting the number right.
So you could argue all this talk
about what the actual number is
is a sort of false
precision if you will,
really what we need to worry
about is getting the sign
right.
And of course,
you will be right.
At the very least,
we to get to the $40.
Of course one big, big
question is it in fact 40?
In which case some
jurisdictions that today have,
let's say, common
price of $15 or so.
That's sort of
within the ballpark.
But it's still clearly
not enough if you
pay $15 per ton of CO2 and
the damage caused by every ton
is, in fact, 40.
But at the very least, you
have the system in place
that will get you there
relatively easily.
Or at least relatively easily
compared to, let's say,
if the real number
is in fact 150, $400
or whatever else it could
be even higher than that.
OK now what to do?
Well, here's what not to do.
I'm not talking about either
having kids or flying.
That's my kid flying when he
was three weeks old on his way
to visit his
grandparents in Austria.
He is wearing a small
carbon footprint hat.
Let's take another image here.
Same example here.
Now, when I say what
not to do I mean
we ought not to look
at this and then say,
oh, well, this is clearly out.
This by the way is to me
or at least a free upgrade
from British Airways.
Thank you BA.
It's pretty nice, three windows,
fruit basket, class of wine.
Of course it's my
laptop here writing
a paper on funding the
term to climate safety.
And you could
basically look at this
and say, well, as
the good upstanding
environmentalist
you really shouldn't
be doing this kind of thing.
Or you should be acting more
in line with this ad here.
And a course, there's
a very good reason
why we should in fact
take these kinds of steps,
the right things, as it were.
Recycle do all the right things.
I don't have a driver's license.
I try to do all
the right things.
Now of course, I
fly quite a bit.
And take these voluntary steps.
Just ethically do
the right thing.
And of course, I teach my
kid to do exactly that too.
Now, here's a good example.
This was in fact a full
page ad in "The New York
Times" on Black Friday,
day after Thanksgiving.
So Patagonia paid
$40,000 or however much
it costs for a full-page
ad to tell people not
to buy their product.
First of all, I can tell you
it's a pretty good jacket.
My wife owns two of them.
I also did go to
the Patagonia store
at that point in the Upper
West Side, Columbus Avenue
in Manhattan the day after.
As a good environmentalist,
of course,
you don't walk into a
store on Black Friday
because that's the
day you don't shop.
So I checked Saturday,
the following day.
Turns out they were sold out.
So advertisement works, right?
Of course it does, right?
So this is the
kind of thing that
appeals to well, you and
me, the kind of people
who know where Patagonia is.
Not the store,
the actual region.
And well, you read the
text and this is fantastic.
It makes you feel good
every step along the way
while wearing the
jacket of course.
And it's a pretty
darn good jacket.
Now, OK, what do I mean when I
say this is not the right step?
If it's basically
personal sacrifice,
if we rely on personal sacrifice
to fix this problem-- climate
in this case-- we are losing.
There's just no way.
That doesn't mean we shouldn't
appeal to ethics as it were.
It would be great.
So sooner rather than later,
throw out all the economists
and sort of make
this an issue just
like child labor essentially.
Something not to be done.
Polluting CO2 is
just something we
can't, shouldn't,
wouldn't want to do
because it is unethical to do.
Fine, all right, sure.
I live in 02138.
Sign me up.
Of course.
On the other hand,
it's just not the way
to in fact get to
where we need to be.
The one thing we have
an economics literally,
the one law we have in
economics is the law of demand.
Price goes up, demand goes down.
Technically that's the law of
compensated demand and there
are, in fact, a
couple of exceptions.
CO2 isn't one of them.
You increase the price of CO2,
demand for the CO2 goes down.
$150 above $150 at
this point is the price
of each ton of CO2 in the
heating sector, the transport
sector in Sweden.
So Sweden is one of
the notable exceptions
of the price on CO2
certainly is negative
or for that matter, too low.
One could argue
possibly the other way.
But the average Swede
pays an average of $150
and above for each ton of CO2.
So two things.
Well, guess what happens in
the Swedish home heating sector
or electricity for that matter?
It's basically decarbonized.
Now, Sweden also happens to be
a pretty darn cold place most
of the time.
It also is a pretty
wealthy place.
So no one's freezing.
Certainly not because of this.
Certainly not because
of the price of CO2.
Well, for that matter, I just
talked to the average Swede
when you come home for dinner
and guess what they talk about?
Their wives and girlfriends
and husbands and boyfriends,
they don't talk about
the price on CO2.
Life goes on.
It just happens to be much,
much more decarbonized.
Market forces still operate.
They just happen to be pointing
in the right direction.
And at that point, of
course, we then easily
should have the conversations
around the ethics
and everything else.
And for that matter,
we can and should
and must have the
conversation around the ethics
to get there in the first place.
But the point is that we need
to get to something like this.
At the very least
a positive price
on CO2 to not guide all of
us in the wrong direction
but at the very least
in the right direction.
So far I talked about
what we don't know.
This is very quick.
I guess these are the chapters,
literally, from the book.
911 is pretty obvious.
411, directory assistance
right here is where we are.
Then the business around
what we don't know.
Now here are these
asterisks to all of this.
And not the asterisks
on the bottom
that says that people said
nice things about the book.
But the actual asterisks
to what we don't know.
What we don't know
basically means
that things will
just be much more
costly than we can imagine.
And what's driving this?
Well, what's driving the
fact that we are talking
about climate change at all is
in fact what economists would
call a free rider problem.
It's not in anyone's
personal short term
immediate economic interest to
do enough or for that matter,
is it possible to do
enough as an individual
to solve this problem
for the rest of us
by decreasing CO2 emissions?
If all of us here were or every
committed environmentalist
on the planet decreased
their emissions
to zero that would be laudable.
That would be good.
A, it probably wouldn't
even be possible.
And I would even
question the statement
whether it would
be good overall.
Given current
technologists that's
just not what we
could reasonably do.
Well, turn this on its head.
From the free rider
problem of it's
not in any one
ours interest to do
enough to what we call
the free driver problem.
When you look at something like
the what techno fix, quick fix,
like geoengineering.
Dumping stuff into
the stratosphere
to deflect sunlight and cooling
the planet while we are at it.
Now, it turns out in
a very big crude form.
we know that works.
Volcanoes have been
doing it forever.
At Mount Pinatubo,
Philippines, 1991,
decreased global average
warming the following year
by about 0.5 degrees
centigrade, which at the time
was precisely the global
average warming up
to that point since
pre-industrial times.
It works.
Now, first of all, I mean
one good way, frankly
of describing what
geoengineering actually
is, is it's basically
chemotherapy for the planet.
So just because some
experimental drug
worked on some rat
somewhere in a lab
in not spreading cancer quite
as rapidly as it would have,
doesn't mean you should
start smoking today.
That's clearly not.
Or like another analogy,
tracheotomy for the planet.
So you probably
want to your doctor
to have that in his back pocket
when you walk into the office.
You probably don't want to
deal with a doctor who doesn't
know what a tracheotomy is.
Let's put it that way.
Now, you certainly don't
walk into a doctor's office
and say, sir, could you
please cut my throat open?
I always wanted to
see what it's like.
Clearly not.
Now that's what I would
say is a pretty apt analogy
to geoengineering.
It doesn't mean
that we shouldn't
want to see whether it
is in fact something we
could be eventually
forced to many ways use.
We certainly don't want to be
looking at it as anything close
to a solution.
At most it's a complement
to what we are doing
and a very, very poor
stand in for that.
And when I say what
we're doing is getting
rid of CO2 in the first place.
Never mind here is now
the bit that we do know.
The economic forces that
prevent us from doing something
about mitigating CO2
in the first place.
Basically all of
them get flipped when
it comes to geoengineering.
It is so cheap, relatively
speaking, to be dumping
the sulfates into
the stratosphere
to deflect sunlight
that you could
argue the national security
adviser to the Indian Prime
Minister at a time when
the monsoon turned off
and have a billion
people are starving,
would be remiss in not
mentioning the option.
We don't know
whether it'll work.
What we do know is there's
half a billion people
starving right now
because of global warming.
So when you then essentially
turn all these around,
such high leverage, so
cheap, relatively speaking.
In many ways I'm
very, very afraid
that it is not a question of if.
It's a question of when somebody
out there will look at this
and say, hmm, here's our option.
Now, the way we
talk about it well,
bailing out the planet
of course is the chapter
where that would happen.
And then, of course, you
can have fun with this
and say, well,
what about looking
at instead of green finger
you look at gold finger.
One way of looking
at this is OK,
this is sort of the cutesy
way of describing what
could in fact be a scenario.
Of course, none of
this is, in fact,
any more pleasant then
pointing to a tracheotomy
or to chemotherapy
for that matter.
We did attempt to write
it as a screenplay, 007.
Nevertheless, there is
a huge, huge warning
attached to all of this.
And of course, at the end of the
day, well, what can we in fact
do?
So with that, I'll turn
it over to questions.
AUDIENCE: My impression
in this country
is probably the biggest thing
we're dealing with right now
is willful blindness.
And I'm wondering if you could
just talk a little bit more
about that?
GERNOT WAGNER: Willful
blindness, I guess,
is exactly what you
think it would be.
Right?
I mean, at this point there
is no way of describing
what's happening in many
areas or public [INAUDIBLE]--
let's put it that
way-- than to say,
you have to be willfully blind
not to want to look at this
and say, we have to take
care of this problem.
This is frankly the
challenge, right?
So here's one, right?
A very real one.
As soon as you mention
uncertainty in an honest way,
well, uncertainty
means wait and see.
Oh well, we don't
know quite as much.
Looks like we need
to wait and see.
Well, in other
words, really what
we ought to be talking
about isn't uncertainty.
It's risk.
Because when you hear
risk you hear mitigate
or when you hear risk
you think mitigate.
And of course, mitigate has a
very direct implication here.
Mitigate CO2 in the first place.
That was actually
the defined term
of what you ought to be doing.
Never mind that right
as a PhD economist
I'm obligated to tell you
that ever since Frank Knight's
University of Chicago
dissertation in 1923
we have tightly defined
idea that uncertainty
is worse than risk.
Sure, in the new
Chicago library fine.
Or amongst PhD Economists
talking amongst themselves
amongst statisticians.
For the real world
that's just not the case.
So this goes beyond
your question of what
it means to be willfully blind.
But so this is the challenge
for us then, the ones who do
know who understand the
science to then say,
OK, well, we know enough to
know that we have to act.
Let's also figure out how to
convey this message in a way
that in fact resonates.
And talking about climate
uncertainty, for example,
well, we know that that's,
in fact, the proper term.
But in many ways it's
associated with wait and see.
Well, climate risk is
associated with mitigate.
Here is a partial
answer right there.
AUDIENCE: First
of all, thank you.
This has been a
wonderful talk really.
Very much enjoyed it.
This is in some ways
a follow-up question
because the following century
is a little bit interesting
in that there are multiple
ways that civilization
could be destroyed.
We have nuclear weapons.
We could have all nuclear war.
We could have runaway
bio engineered plagues.
What, as an economist who knows
about Knightean uncertainty,
does that make you believe
that how we should balance
or how much we spend on
these various risks given
that many of them actually
have bigger uncertainties
than climate change?
GERNOT WAGNER:
Excellent question.
Turns out climate
change does not
have a monopoly on worst-case
scenarios, yes, absolutely.
Now, we've actually thought
quite a bit about this.
And in fact, the chapter on
willful blindness, half of it
isn't just talking
about willful blindness.
Half of that
chapter is, in fact,
well let's go through the worst
case scenarios and figure out
what makes climate change,
if anything, unique?
And at the end of the day,
we do describe climate change
as uniquely long term, uniquely
global, uniquely irreversible,
and uniquely risky,
uniquely uncertain.
Or at least it's unique in
the combination of all four.
Now, that does not
mean that there
aren't other problems out there
that deserve our attention.
But let me just give
you two examples.
And we go through eight
total then basically
say, well, climate change
isn't in fact the only problem.
But it may be the
only problem where
the disconnect between
public attention
and for that matter, public
action to what science
tells us is in fact necessary is
the largest out of all of them.
We go through nuclear
war and GMOs and so on.
Now, here's two of those
we are considering.
One of asteroids.
The other one are
the strangelets.
Stable strange matter that sort
of sucks up everything and CERN
is now ramping up again and
there's sort of these worries,
right?
Now, asteroids.
arguably 65 million
years ago there
was an asteroid that
wiped out the dinosaurs.
It's not unprecedented.
It has happened before.
And in fact, asteroids
and climate change
are the two, in
this entire category
of all these worst-case
scenarios that are in fact,
have historical precedent.
We can point to
history and say, here's
what will happen based
on what has happened.
OK, asteroids once again.
Right?
So the big ones that's going
to wipe out civilization
as we know are in fact,
a big, big problem.
And we have to do
something about it.
Now, you don't have to be
Armageddon Bruce Willis going
up there and sort of taking
matters in his own hands.
On the other hand, actually, the
nuclear standoff collision kind
of sort of what was featured
in this Hollywood movie
is, in fact, something
that serious scientists,
National Academy
study in this case,
is pointing to as
something that NASA
should in fact be exploring.
And as instance, well, OK,
if you look at the study
and it says, we need about
10 years and 2 to $3 billion
to test one of these
nuclear standoff collisions.
So yeah, that's a
lot of money right?
It's 2 to $3 billion bucks
and it'll take us a decade.
Now, we pretty much know that
none of these sizable asteroids
are going to hit
us within a decade.
So yes we have the time.
We certainly have the money.
And the shorter answer is
let's go spend the money
and invest the resources and
go take care of this problem.
But-- and this is the big
but in this case-- we can,
up to a point-- never
100% certainty--
but we can be pretty darn
sure that if we invest
the resources-- finite amount
of resources in this case--
we can basically check
this worst-case scenario
off our list.
There'll always be smaller
asteroids hitting us.
And in fact, we start the
book with the scenario
of the Russian asteroid
hitting basically
injuring 1,500 people.
Killed no one, injured 1,500.
That's a problem.
And these asteroids are probably
too small to identify and track
and for that matter deflect.
Won't happen.
Every single one of
them we can probably
invest the money to
at least identify
them and tell
people to stay away
from windows for the next hour.
But at the end of the
day it is, in fact,
a relatively small problem.
It's not a worst-case
scenario that
will swallow up the planet.
All right now flip gears.
Strangelets would, in
fact, swallow up the planet
quite literally in a fraction
of a second no one of us
would notice that it happens.
Now, you talk to
theoretical physicists
some would even doubt that
it's theoretically possible.
Which of course is a
whole different matter.
If you can prove that it's
theoretically impossible then
why worry about it?
It might make a good
headline but it's clearly
not something to worry about.
I guess there are
physicists who do
believe that it is at least
theoretically possible
have in fact tried to
do some calculations.
And I forgot the
exact number of zeros
that go between the period
and the actual the two
in this case.
It's 0.00002% of that
in fact being possible.
So no, it's not zero.
And yes, it will be the
ultimate catastrophe,
swallowing up the universe
or the planet, at least,
as we know it.
On the other hand, when you look
at the chance of catastrophe
where we say, well, it's at
least around 10% unless we act.
In that case it is so much
lower that it's not zero
but it might as well be.
Or In other words, all
these other catastrophes,
we look at nuclear catastrophe
and GMOs for that matter.
GMOs is a fantastic
example too, by the way.
So the public is scared.
The average public is scared
of GMOs wreaking havoc.
When you talk to the
well-informed scientist, most
of them-- the vast,
vast majority of them--
are much less worried about the
ultimate worst-case scenario
when it comes to GMOs
than the general public.
Flip gears and look at climate.
The average climate
scientist is most
definitely much,
much more worried
than the average citizen.
Not just here in
the US, everywhere.
Europe, anywhere.
And then what you actually
have is many of the more level
headed climate scientists
have, in fact, moved on.
And not moved on in sort
of worrying about GMOs,
but moved on and
basically are now
thinking about geoengineering.
That's a real problem.
So I'm not saying
climate change is unique.
I would say it's unique in
the combination of these four
long term, global,
irreversible, and uncertain.
Which, of course, makes
it uniquely difficult
to solve which is a
problem, a real problem.
And more important
or equally important,
it is probably the one
problem with the biggest
gap between informed citizens
versus actual action.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
You put up the slide $150
and then you said Sweden.
And I almost tolled
my eyes a little bit.
Because if you had
asked me, OK, make
a list of the most
likely countries that
are making public investments
in reducing climate change,
many of us in this
room ah, Sweden's
probably up there somewhere.
Their approach to
public investment
on particular issues, add
this to the list of things
that Sweden has
done that won't even
put it on the map of
American politics, right?
I guess I'm curious, as
you go down that list.
Are there surprises?
Are there countries whose
economy and other approaches
to public investment
would not lead
you to believe that they
were to climate change
seriously and yet,
that country does?
Because those might be the
countries that we would
want to look to.
Making countries more like
Sweden in all other ways,
and then bringing them
up to the climate change,
may be a harder thing
if there turns out
that there's kind of a shortcut
to this particular issue
of public investment?
GERNOT WAGNER: Yep,
great question.
So yeah, trust the Scandinavians
to always do the right thing
even though it's not in
this narrow self interest.
Right?
Now, it turns out, yes there is.
India has $1 per ton
of coal, coal tax.
Not CO2 tax, coal tax.
Price on coal.
Raising half a
billion dollars a year
and spending it for the
most part on renewables,
the kind of stuff you would
expect that money to be used.
China is experimenting now with
seven regional cap and trade
trials.
And NDRC, the National
Development Reform Commission
is essentially writing the next
five-year plan as we speak.
And it will very
likely have something
akin to a national
cap on emissions
at least for the electricity
sector, let's say,
which of course, is the big one.
For the matter when you
look what is actually
happening in reality, well,
Chinese coal consumption
has, in fact, peaked.
It did peak two
years ago, I guess.
It went down last year.
When you look at
global CO2 emissions
from the energy sector, not
global greenhouse gas emissions
from everything, but CO2 from
the energy sector-- which
in many ways, is in fact,
the most important gas
from the most important sector--
has for the very first time
ever since IEA-- the
international Energy
Administration's been
keeping track of these things
but now 40 years-- been leveling
off during 2013 and 2014
without a recession,
without a global recession.
In part as a result
of China's coal
use peaking in part
because emissions in the US
have been going down,
because we're switching
from coal to natural gas and
renewables in energy efficiency
about a third, a third,
a third contributing
here in the US and
lots of other factors.
And of course,
right, I'm obligated
to tell you that leveling
emissions isn't enough.
Now we are filling the
bathtub at a steady rate.
But we are still filling
the atmospheric bathtub.
Which is, by the way, one
of these-- in many ways--
very, very simple concepts
that when you, to be fair,
not explain it with
a bathtub analogy
but explain it in sort
of climate context,
you quiz 200 above average
MIT graduate students.
They get that wrong.
They think that leveling
off emissions is the goal.
When you think about
it as a bathtub
it's pretty darn obvious
that that's not the case.
Your bathtub will still
overflow if you have kept
the inflow of water steady.
What we have to do is
turn down the flow.
Get to zero and even
below zero in order
to stabilize global
average temperatures.
So it's a heavy, heavy lift.
That said, positive
examples-- well,
we've seen the US China
climate deal last November.
That in many ways no
one really expected.
And yes, it is ambitious
yet achievable goals
for the two largest
economies, the two largest
emitters of CO2.
And it was a clear
positive step forward.
Well, for that matter,
very concretely.
Right?
California eighth or ninth
largest economy on the planet
independently has
a cap on emissions,
has a price on CO2 as a result.
And emissions are going down.
So it's certainly
not just Sweden.
There are certainly
also some unexpected.
And by the way, China and India
are, in fact, very unexpected.
The Climate bill,
Waxman-Markey Bill on page one
mentioned two countries.
None of them was the US,
it was China, and India.
And it was in the context
of unless China and India,
we won't.
Well, now you look
at China and India
and they are the ones, in fact,
taking some of these steps that
are necessary.
Not enough, but still, steps
that are in fact pointing
in the right direction.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]